[Music]
the nick and artie show this is a sports
show uh nick you actually played
collegiate ball did you not i played up
at maine if you want to call that
collegiate ball yes and uh
well
22 white guys you gonna really scare
anybody
we're running back from lewiston look
out
but we had injuries when you're playing
football in the woods you know it's
different right and up in the woods in
college like our quarterback was day to
day with a tech bite
it's a true you're laughing but it's
true
all right well you have this show and
this seems like kind of a dream job
because
directv the show is on you're doing a
show for direct tv right it's gonna be
on it's going to be on the audience
network on directv in the spring
right but they produce the radio show
right now they do the radio show but
they are building you a set where they
pretty much told you we will build you a
man cave
anything you guys want will be in the
man cave you guys know from dealing with
network executives that when you say a
joke that you really think is funny or
edgy they're going to turn it down right
these guys will do anything we say stuff
that they as a joke that they think will
turn they said what do you want on the
wall we'll frame anything on the wall
my first suggestion was a velvet
painting of uh michael vick playing
poker with uh pit bulls
and they're like i threw that out
kiddingly and they're like that's a
great idea right there don't do it
is this painting going to be made yes
there's a woman working on it already
you've got a better one right has a
better one there's abroad in the loft in
brooklyn right now painting
no these guys not just yes that's
hilarious write that down to some woman
okay that's great i said to myself i
gotta try to think of one for me so they
said what do you want on the wall and i
said i want o.j simpson photoshopped
with tim tebow
and i want the caption to say o.j
simpson and a white bronco
that's the show you're gonna get it's a
good show yeah
and again you know you guys know now can
we can't yes
that's hilarious
[Laughter]
i'm gonna watch the show just for the
stuff you guys have hanging on the wall
uh all right so you guys cover sports
i'm just curious what's your least
favorite sport to cover
oh well easy for me what's that soccer
you hate soccer yeah it's too gay
i don't mean gay gay you know what i
mean i mean
you want to clarify it yes i do it's for
11 year old girls and uh gay guys from
france but uh
no here's what i mean
it's it's political it's you're digging
the whole deep i know this is what i'm
trying to help you out no i'm gonna lose
that beckham contract i got more gay
friends than kelly ripper so relax all
right
i i doubt that
i don't like it it's so politically
correct conan they don't keep scoring on
youth soccer you know your kids probably
yeah they're afraid if the kid loses a
soccer game it's going to hurt their
self-esteem right losing a soccer game
is not going to hurt a little girl's
self-esteem having her drunk uncle try
to kiss her at a cookout
that's gonna
i'm supposed to believe these are the
options
there's no gray area
it's that or that i'm supposed to
believe tammy became a stripper because
you missed a penalty kick in high school
you know
that means come on
all right well what's your favorite
sport to cover college football because
football i like college how do you like
i like pro football because i'm a giant
fan and he's a patriot fan
and i'm a patriots fan
and we're out of time
like the patriots were out of time all
right
you hold them i'll kick them
that was great you're still drinking out
of a mug with my name on it
i know this is my own small way i win
so you lose o'brien
good conan juice god i think i think
it's clear i think it's clear you're
winning in a lot more ways